[Music]
hello am i on
yeah am i on welcome hey uh hey sonia
how are you
good good i'm excited to have you bye
and it's great it's cool to be here and
and blay does this too
right yeah he is here as well yeah man i
do this too
sonya and i get along great i don't know
what it is
but we just have a certain great
chemistry
and uh energy yeah and lay one day
if you and i hang out for maybe 50 more
years
we will have the same feelings about
each other
as long as you're here let's put you to
work do you mind like can we just get
your thoughts on on a very popular game
right now yes
as everyone knows i don't know a lot
about games
and i'm not good at games but i love
having a lot of opinions about games
and sharing those with people in the
legitimate gaming world
thus infuriating them so please
tell me what you got and i will render
an incredibly
unfair and invalid opinion all right so
here's i'm going to show you it's called
among us
oh my god wait i know about among us
i'll tell you why
my son had his birthday the other day
and i guess he and his friends
love among us and so he got this gift
that completely baffled me
a friend of his went on etsy and had
someone
crochet him his favorite character from
among us
and so he took this thing out of a box
and it was this little
blip blorp like a little purple blip
blorp and he was like oh man i can't
believe it
this is so funny and my my daughter was
jumping up and down and they were both
high-fiving each other and he was
laughing and saying i can't believe it
it's gleep gloop
and i was like i don't know what's
happening again i don't know what the
name of it was
he said the name but i often tune out
when my children are talking to me about
video games or how they feel about
things so
i probably wasn't paying attention it
was a purple
and it had like this white panel on the
front of it
and they were all very excited so i have
no idea what it's about my guess is it's
a bunch of crocheted
blip blops and blurt bleeps that live
together
and uh whoever whoever's yarn holds up
for the longest time is the winner
that's the closest i have no idea what
it's about
that's pretty close you're basically on
a ship with a bunch of other people
as blip blorps and you're trying to get
the ship going and get out of there
before imposters which are among your
crew members
uh try to kill you before and you have
to try to figure out
who the imposters are and kick them off
before it happens
um so basically you just find out who
out of your friends are the best
pathological liars is this a game that
you can play on tablets
yes yes okay okay wow
my kids were having like a socially
distance they were outside and they were
playing this game and i guess they
wanted someone else to come
so they got me this is i don't know this
is like a month and a half ago to come
outside
and they handed me a tablet
and yes i guess it looked like we were
in some sort of machine
room and we were wandering around and
i didn't know it but apparently i was
the murderer
or imposter and i just got near somebody
and they it said i killed them but i
didn't push any buttons or do anything
and they said to me the kids were like
you're really good at this game
and i didn't know what i was doing they
afterwards said oh yeah i didn't know
what you were doing you killed two of us
and i said i wandered from room to room
and got near one of you and you died and
then i got a near another one of you
and you died and i didn't even know that
i was the problem
any game where an idiot can just jump in
for fun
and win it's like our presidential
election any game where an idiot can
jump in
just willy-nilly and suddenly rock it to
the top and triumph
uh that's a problem with that game i'm
glad you're just a natural at this game
i feel like you should own that
you should own that that's creepy that
the game that rewards
uh soulless pathological
uh liars is something that i can just
jump into and immediately because
i'm very good at it and i don't even
know it but you know what i've been
working in show business
for 30 years and so maybe that prepared
me for this game
it all came to this final verdict on
among us
i have to tell you my kids go crazy for
this game they really love it
my son now has a crocheted whatever that
thing is and he'll probably treasure it
for the rest of his life
i don't get it i played it once briefly
uh without even knowing i was playing it
and the fact
that i was very good at it
instantly without even knowing i was
playing
yeah that worries me so
that's i have technically yes i didn't
know it was called among us but i have
played this game
but had no idea what i was doing
absolutely no idea what i was doing
and i was confused and yet this says
something about the game afterwards they
were like
you're badass man and high-fiving me
that means it's a bad game
judgment rendered
well thanks for stopping by appreciate
i'm not going i'm not going anywhere
oh i'm going to stay here until i ruin
everything about this podcast oh gosh
this is the ultimate payback play
uh sonia i'm sorry you had to be caught
in the crossfire but i need to destroy
this podcast now
because it's something that might help
play and might give him some joy
so what you did sonia is you hitched
your wagon
to a death star that's what i'm here for
we'll find you something else
oh thank you at least i'm gonna be
placed elsewhere
in the giant conan evil empire yeah
right blai i'm sorry to have to do this
to you